hey everybody welcome to another edition
of rollback the series that introduces a
selection
of pre-video audio only episodes of our
show to youtube for the very first time
and today's episode is all about
loving kindness
how we can better cultivate and expand
our experience of love in our daily
lives with meta meditation master sharon
salzberg sharon is a world renowned
meditation teacher and new york times
best-selling author who's played a
crucial role in bringing meditation and
mindfulness practices to mainstream
western culture dating all the way back
to 1974.
she's the author of 11 books including
loving kindness
real happiness real change and real love
the art of mindful connection which was
the focus of this conversation recorded
back in the spring of
2017. sharon is also our regular
columnist for on being she's a
contributor to huffpo
and the host of her own podcast the meta
hour
this conversation is one of my favorites
and serves as a deep dive into sharon's
extraordinary life
it's a discussion about how we think
about and practice love both for
ourselves and for others and examines
how meditation can help us master what
sharon considers to be
the three most essential skills in life
compassion
mindfulness and concentration
i think you're really gonna love the
product of our exchange so please hit
that subscribe button and enjoy episode
298 with sharon salzburg
thank you for taking the time to chat
today oh it's a great delight really
yeah so um
maybe you know perhaps the best sort of
intro point or way into this is just to
crack it wide open with with real love i
mean this is the name of the new book
um
it's great i'm about halfway through it
i'm not totally done with it but it's
fabulous congratulations yeah thank you
i can't wait for people to experience
uh the beauty and the wisdom in that so
you know why don't you define for us
what real love is you know what's the
difference between
how we you know conceptualize love in
our current culture and you know your
your take on it that's the killer
question of this right we'll just spend
the next two hours talking about this
what is real love i have to figure it
out
um
i usually talk about it as a state of
really profound connection
that needs to take it take that concept
away from
kind of the adornments you know and the
elaborations that the culture puts on it
that has to be romantic
it has to have a certain flavor
almost the whole book actually oddly
enough is
born out of this one line in a movie the
movie dan in real life
the line goes love is not a feeling it's
an ability
and of course we know it is a feeling we
yearn for it as a feeling we think of it
constantly sometimes as a feeling but
what if we reconceptualize that as an
ability some capacity we have within us
that's not in the hands of someone else
but is really part of us and that other
people may awaken it or enliven it or
nourish it or threaten it but it's
within us so
i realized that
without that shift i tended to think of
love as a commodity
and it's almost like a package and it's
like the ups person was standing in the
doorstep with
that package in his hand and
changed his mind and went the other way
and it'd be like hey wait a minute you
know right i've lost all the love in my
life but really it's within us and
uh that was a huge shift for me
and how did you well i guess that's
going to bring it back i want to get
into the whole origin story we'll we'll
work our way towards that for for
context
but you break the book up into three
sections it's basically
love for oneself love for others and and
love for all right and you kind of
um it's a journey towards reclaiming
this word and freeing it of all the
baggage that we kind of associate with
it
and and you know placing it in a context
really as a verb right and not something
to be
um
not this sort of
state or
something that we're striving for or
trying to get from another by trying to
really kind of germinate and cultivate
within ourselves that's right and it
i think that that realization has every
level to it including the fact that
maybe it's up to us then you know which
can be a little scary
like whoa wait a minute you know we
don't want to take personal
responsibility you know that's not fun
yeah so you know oh you know maybe the
package is a better deal but um yeah it
has lots of levels but that's exactly it
when i first
was thinking about this book and and
uh kind of creating it and i talked to
someone in publishing about it
they said to me oh the love market's
really saturated
you know it's like so overdone and i
thought about that and i thought well
maybe the how to fix your relationship
marketer right find your romantic love
that's right
you know but this is something this is
something very different
it's not a mistake that that you know
the first section is cultivating love
for oneself right and and i think we
you know in our current society think of
self-love as indulgent or selfish or
narcissistic or an exercise of the ego
but really you know cultivating love for
oneself is a foundational component in
actually even having the capacity to
love other people so can you talk about
that a little bit yeah i mean i think we
tend to think of uh self-love as
narcissism
and being selfish and like you say
self-indulgent but
i think it has two really amazing
components one is a sense of inner
resource not feeling so exhausted and
bereft and impoverished within
but having a sense of inner sufficiency
or even inner abundance which becomes
like the source of being able to give
and care and take care of others you
know it's like if you feel like you've
got nothing going on inside
nothing to contribute
uh it's kind of a really bleak and
hollow world within
you don't look at somebody in pain and
think how can i help you you know it's
like go away i'm really tired you know
it's too much i can't bear it and we
truly can't bear it in that moment
but we have the capacity to
um have a very different view of our
inner life and
our experiences that it doesn't feel so
bleak and it doesn't feel so
uh not good enough
and the other part of the love for
oneself is self-compassion which really
comes into play not in our triumphs you
know in our great days but when we've
blown it and we've made a mistake or
we've
fallen off a course that we want to stay
on or
whatever it is you know to be able to
pick ourselves up and start over
and have a sense of resilience
really takes some examination a lot of
people think self-compassion
is laziness it's like yeah so what i'll
forgive myself and blow it again intense
like letting yourself off the hook for
everything that's right that's right but
really i think when we look at what's
most effective and most efficient in
making a change or getting something
done it's not going on a harangue
towards yourself for like five and a
half hours after you've blown it
you know it's like saying okay lessons
learned or something like that or that
doesn't feel very good or what can i do
to make amends and then start over
most of us walk around with an
inordinate amount of self-judgment and
self-criticism and doubt and
you know an undercurrent of
worthlessness or you know i'm not worthy
of love and and we play this tape in our
mind right and and i think when you're
in that spot
um whether it's victimization or just
sort of you know wallowing in your own
fear or what have you
you tend to look outside yourself for
love like you you you look at another
person as being the missing
variable in that equation that's going
to solve that for yourself as opposed to
that inward journey of cultivating it
within
but the problem of course is that
nothing you know will actually fill that
gap right nothing outside and then
i took in the book we know that
intellectually
you know well i think a lot of people do
and we but we still do it of course we
do it you know and it hurts so much it's
really sad
um of course we do it but that's where
there's some self-compassion right there
um
but we don't have to do it in as
obsessed away and as diluted away
perhaps as we once did because we can
see clearly we can see for ourselves you
know the
i think that the world is is built of so
many myths and
just untruths and
we're
led to believe so many things that
simply aren't true
and we incorporate them we run around
trying to find the perfect whatever
and sometimes we can step back and say
wait a minute
do i really need that or what's the
nature of that and even love itself
comes under that that idea because so
many times people think of love as being
stupid or you know like sentimental or
weak or weak or saccharine and and you
know what's really strong is like
vengefulness or
whatever but when you look at those
states just look at them
uh it's kind of the opposite actually
eventualness is very narrow very much
tunnel vision
very much um not seeing any options
uh hateful you know it doesn't feel
really that good and it's kind of
brittle you know it's not really that
strong but
love or compassion are states of
tremendous like spaciousness and
um
presence and you know energy and
generosity they are actually stronger
than we think yeah i think it's a it's a
position of strength but it lacks that
rush you know that we get addicted to
and we can become addicted to that anger
response or vengefulness and those are i
think i've heard you describe it they're
they're like brush fires you know they
they burn very intensely but ultimately
they're not sustainable over the long
run you're right and so you know love
and compassion are deeper reservoirs
that can sustain us over the long haul
and you know i can't we can't talk about
this without sort of contextualizing it
with what's going on currently
culturally you know we're in a we're in
a tremendously divisive situation at the
moment uh socially
and we see a lot of anger we see a lot
of it's almost like
suddenly there's permission for a lot of
this anger and vengefulness and
resentment to birth itself and and
manifests itself in in some pretty
unhealthy ways
uh
you know how does how does real love
play into that in terms of how we
navigate the world and and respond to
that and you know tend our own emotional
bodies and you know what i mean like in
terms of boundaries and
and you know just the daily
conversations that we have
i think it has a lot to do with balance
it's like
um there there's a real need to i don't
know that we ever understand these
things intellectually or analytically
but to explore terrains of what could it
possibly mean
to
have love and compassion for ourselves
and for someone else at the same time or
what could it mean to have compassion
for someone and realize i agree with
nothing they are proposing and i'm going
to fight
but not perhaps from a place of hatred
a place of of neutrality
yeah it's a place of balance of of
wishing that everyone could be free
and that i mean i've worked with people
for example with
horribly abusive parents i'm horribly
abusive parents he said i can't find the
phrase you know like what would i
possibly
uh be offering you know and i said can
you say maybe free of hatred they said
yeah that i can say
um
and something like that it's it's it's a
profound
exploration but i really do believe that
our kind of
corrosive rigid sense of self and other
where the other doesn't count you know
it doesn't matter um
is it the root of of a lot of the really
scary stuff that's going on i find it
scary too you know i live part-time in
new york city
uh in greenwich village and you know a
block away people are painting swastikas
on walls and i think wait a minute you
know like
this is really scary um
but i don't think fear is the basis for
going forward in a good way in a
skillful way and i think the sense of
otherness like
it doesn't matter what happens to you
you're like a chair you know you're not
like a person right um
is at the root of a lot of that behavior
and so i don't want to perpetrate that
myself
uh but i also do strongly believe in the
power of love or the strength of love
and compassion it's not like being meek
and obsequious and giving in you know i
think it's a whole other source of
of strength that can have us have us
really fight
there's a phrase in uh in recovery
parlance that's that goes like this uh
you cannot give something that you
haven't got
uh do you think that applies to
you know how you how you think about
love in the sense that you're really not
capable of truly loving another uh
until you love yourself are they are
they exclusive in that regard
i actually don't think they're that
completely exclusive um
i had a conversation with someone bell
hooks in new york city and she called me
on that you know she didn't agree with
that she thought they were
you really had to love yourself before
you could love someone else she said
you can care for someone or care about
them but you can't really love them
unless you love yourself and i said well
you know i feel like i know people
who do love others but you can't in the
long term sustain that without love for
yourself then right you know generosity
becomes martyrdom or gets weird or
distorted and you no longer actually
really caring you're
you know calculating like how much have
i given you that you're not returning
you know yeah you're taking a balance
sheet but i i think that that there is
a sort of act as if
mentality that you can appropriate yeah
i i i'm thinking of this that animated
video that you voiced the other day i
shared that on social media the other
day so beautiful were you like a llama
what was the uh what was the animal that
you're dug yeah
yeah but it's basically the story you
could tell the story better than i but
essentially it's it's
you know how we interact with the people
on a daily basis the cashier at the
restaurant or the store and how we look
through them as opposed to you know at
them and this idea that you
even if you're not feeling it like to
you know what i'm gonna make a choice
i'm gonna i'm gonna actually engage this
person that's right and and and try to
you know see them as a whole human being
yeah and even if you're lacking that
compassion for yourself
that you know sort of adopting that
behavior modality
uh
can reframe yeah how you you know not
just interact with others but how you
see yourself in the sense that you know
self-esteem comes from performing
esteemable acts and if you get into the
habit of doing that you are cultivating
self-love in some regard by loving
others oh i think you really are that's
that's well well said and there's
something about that act that returns us
to something inside of ourselves that is
whole
you know that may be hidden or hard to
see or obscured in some way but in that
act if it's done you know purely
that's what we touch in on again it's
like oh and that you know the reason for
the animation was which i also think is
extremely cute and it's really cute um
i've never seen i said when i shared it
i was like i should actually watch this
every day
because i have to be reminded
you know i look through people as much
as the next person
we all do
um you know it's sort of like the second
great controversy after love is weak and
sort of stupid is that
um
i think
in eastern philosophy love is quite
trainable uh it's a skill and it's a
skill it's it's trainable because it's
based on how we pay attention
and we know attention is trainable
that's all that meditation is is
training attention
so it's not like you're forcing yourself
to feel something you don't really feel
or you're
you're being hypocritical and covering
over some really difficult feelings with
this little veneer you know of sweetness
it's not like that but paying attention
differently will lay the ground for love
to emerge and so
it's it's completely here too it's
almost in our hands you know right do we
want to cultivate that skill or not so
like you said you go into that store and
you look at the person
not through them something happens
yeah by honing your attention by really
focusing on your attention by practicing
this
skill
uh you create that space that allows it
to come in and i like that idea because
it allows you to take personal
responsibility for your ability to love
others and yourself as opposed to
waiting for it to come you know in this
you know romantic notion of how we you
know sort of typically think about love
yeah how do you think of how do you
communicate
about this subject with men versus women
like is there a a difference in the
vocabulary they use i mean i think that
it's you know
am i going far afield to say that you
know it's trickier with men because men
are a little bit more clamped down and
you know even saying the word out loud
can be challenging for a lot and it it
sort of
it sort of
challenges you know ideas about
masculinity and strength and all these
you know kind of cultural identity
issues that get played into
well another uh genesis of the book was
um
a conversation i had with a friend of
mine who's a man who who was saying that
in his mind the movement from a more um
conventional kind of love
to more of a state of real love was in a
way moving out of the center of
privilege
to really listen to his partner in a
different way so he said you know his
wife suggested something he didn't
really want to do
but he thought you know what it works
for her
and it's not that convenient for me
but it's what she wants so why should
everything be referenced to my needs you
know my demands and
um
and i i would say to him in response you
know there's an awful lot of people
usually women in this world who never
voice their demands or their their needs
you know so for them
moving to a more real kind of love or a
liberated kind of love might be actually
expressing what who they are
you know and what they desire and i like
those two polarities they're actually
both in the book
um i changed his name but
you know uh it was it was so interesting
to me to watch that i mean i think
there's movement and growth for anybody
and depending on your
if you think about it as balance uh
although it's not that you know sexy a
word but i think it really is a state of
balance it's instead of some repose or
harmony and we're out of harmony one way
or another and
uh the story i told about from the
women's side was about a friend of mine
who
uh
outlived her cancer prognosis i think by
40 years something like that
and she was telling me about her early
healing journey when she was first sort
of looking at her life and
everything in her life and she said i
used to be the kind of woman
who i'd be sitting in the car with my
husband boiling hot and the most i could
ever bring myself to say is are you warm
dear
you know
so that's a big contrast to my other
friend you know who
who's saying you know what it can't all
be about me
right and so i think that's also that's
like the magic of a creative
process you know is is that dynamism of
leaving where we are if we're stuck
and in some kind of rut and moving to
another place
of getting outside yourself yeah and
your own ideas and and needs and and
thinking about those of the other yeah
or your own in her case you know yeah do
you
do you
when you talk about love and real love
is this a unifying singular concept
because i when i think about love i
think you know well there's the way i
love my wife and that's different from
how i love my kids and
how i love my parents
you know how do you how do you
parse that
um i think it's both you know the
manifestation the feeling will be very
different people would often ask that in
in classes like
i want to love everybody but i kind of
like my husband a lot you know like do
you have to give him up you know
you have to go back in the pool or
something you know
uh no i mean of course we have i mean we
would say you know in in buddhist
teaching would say we have different
karma with different people but
um
you know that's a little bit esoteric a
way of saying it but we do have
different
roles or relationships with different
people they're going to feel very
different they're going to manifest
differently
but there's something about that kind of
pure connection
where we're just there
that i think is actually the same
and it's maybe
maybe most complicated actually with
children
because of the responsibility of you
know needing to protect them and take
care of that but it goes back to
honing your attention yeah right and
mindfulness and and and meditation and
you know that that journey to being able
to do that right we're gonna we're gonna
talk about that so let's
contextualize this i wanna i wanna go
back to the to the you know the origin
story here
because uh it's quite remarkable the
journey that you've been on to be able
to do what you do today
so take me back to the early days in new
york city and your life oh yeah
so i had a very um
traumatic you know
disordered chaotic kind of childhood i
uh when i wrote this book called faith i
looked back which is sort of my faith
journey i looked back and i realized
that by the time
i went to college at the age of 16 i
lived in five different family
configurations every one of them
shifted because of a death or some loss
or some profound
um craziness and
so my
parents got divorced when i was four my
father disappeared and
i was with my mother and her siblings
until i was nine then my mother died
very suddenly
and i lived with my father's parents
whom i hardly knew my father didn't
reappear for another couple of years
so my grandfather died his father died
and then
my father came back and he was back for
about six weeks when he took an overdose
of sleeping pills
and ended up in
some mental health facility or another
for the rest of his life which was you
know pretty extensive
um
that's either va hospital nursing home
or sometimes on the streets if
you would run away or something like
that and sometimes you'd be better and
sometimes you'd be not so well so was
there a diagnosis for that
well i think his actual diagnosis was
paranoid schizophrenic what whether in
those days
um
those were done with tremendous accuracy
or not i'm not really sure
but
i then i live with my grandmother until
i went to college at the age of 16. so
that that means so five five different
incarnations and and
and
a tragic you know
occurrence in each one of those that you
had to weather at a very early age yeah
yeah the trauma of that i i can't even
fathom
it's amazing you made it through that
and and you know we're able to kind of
get through high school and get yourself
to college right yeah do you remember
feeling like when you went away to you
went upstate to college
buffalo so do you do you remember
feeling a like a sense of free like i
need to get away from this or what was
the you know kind of emotional
experience yeah
it was close to that it wasn't exactly i
need to get away from this but i kept
thinking this is something else
there's something
and
and how are you carrying your suffering
at that time
i was like completely isolated i was
very shut down i was
very unhappy but not expressive of it i
didn't know how to i didn't even know
what was happening within me it's
actually only when i started meditating
uh when i went to india
that i began uncovering kind of the
range of what you know the range of what
i was experiencing which was rage and
fear and you know sadness and all these
things and i found that shocking you
know i didn't know i felt this right
yeah you talk about that in the book
the experience that a lot of people have
when they when they begin
you know kind of an intensive meditation
practice for the first time they think
they're all good you know and then
suddenly they're crying uncontrollably
and they have all this rage or whatever
and they're like i thought this was
supposed to make me i thought i was
happy right
like
this is this is a [ __ ] you know yeah and
you're saying no you're exactly where
where you need to be because you're
actually confronting your suffering for
the very first time and that's it that's
part of this process of you know
acknowledgement and and ultimately
working through it i mean this is a
little bit my story's a little bit in
this book it's it's much more extensive
than this book faith and
many many people come up to me and say i
had a childhood just like yours or i
really understand so it's hardly rare
actually
all right so you're in buffalo and you
find yourself in like an asian studies
class right
do you remember what
pulled you towards that class to begin
with was there like a conscious or
unconscious you know
magnetizing force to that it's a little
bit like some of it was really just
convenience it fit into my schedule yeah
i needed to do a philosophy course
because there's a requirement some of it
was it was kind of in the air you know
the beatles had gone to india right
everyone was like maharishi yeah
maharishi was around people were looking
at like indian music and
sitar's and you know chai hadn't hit yet
you know that hadn't come out much later
but
i don't know where the clothes but you
know it was what was happening i went to
school in the 60s you know
um
and it was really in the asian
philosophy course that
and two things happened one was
in the component on buddhism which was
most of it
when i heard the buddha say there's
suffering in life
that this is a natural part of life um
it was the most probably the most
liberating thing i've ever heard right
to be born is to suffer to be born is to
suffer and
it was finally the thought it's not just
me
you know because i've been so different
from everybody else all those years like
what do you say in
french class when you're supposed to say
what your father does for a living in
french it's like i don't know how to say
this
you know or uh and suddenly
there was no sense of being excluded you
know it's like we're all suffering
this is not always you know not not that
life is horrible but there's always
suffering in someone's life
somewhere along the line and
and that's the truth and i felt
incredibly freed just by that statement
and then i heard about these
practices called meditation where you
could actually do something
about your mind and be happier and it
was like i looked around buffalo new
york and at that time i didn't find it
anywhere you know might have been there
but now it's probably everywhere but
uh i just didn't see it so the school
had an independent study program where
if you created a project that they liked
you could go anywhere uh for a year
theoretically
and then come back so i created a
project i want to go to india right it's
interesting do you think that if you had
decided to go to like city college in
new york or or or something like that
that you would have ended up in analysis
you know
i never i never thought like a very
woody allen kind of way
that's very funny i never thought of
that no i i don't think no
i mean
you know when we finish telling your
whole story i mean it's it's always that
thing of like when you look back in the
rearview mirror everything lines up
perfectly uh do you do you think about
it in terms of of fate do you feel like
like you know like this was on some
level a predestined course for you or
that you were tapping into some kind of
past life experience that led you
towards this
uh i don't think of it exactly as firmly
as fate but
uh i think it was meant to be in a way
you know like or i managed somehow i
managed to use it in a way that was
right really good like when
you know i stayed in india for more than
a year i came back finished school went
back to india and then when i was
leaving in 1974
for what i thought was going to be a
very brief visit home
before i lived in india for the rest of
my life i went to see one of my teachers
who was a woman named deepama deepam was
like a nickname deeply's mother
and
she was a woman who had suffered
terribly in her life and that's how
she'd gotten into practice she had
three children two of whom died her
husband died really suddenly
uh and she developed his heart condition
she like went to bed she was living in
berm at the time
she couldn't get out of bed and the
doctor came and said
you're actually going to die of a broken
heart unless you do something about your
mind you should learn how to meditate
so she got out of bed and uh
she went to the retreat center and when
she emerged
somehow she had metabolized all of that
horrible
grief and pain into some kind of
compassion for everybody it was like
this enormous radiance she had
and uh she was my teacher and so i went
to see her say goodbye
for my short short trip home and she
said
when you get to the stage she'll be
teaching and i said no i won't
i said yes i said i want and said yes
you well he said no one
and you're like 21 at this point
yeah and and she said two things that
were really amazing the first was
she said you really understand suffering
that's why you should teach
and that was the first moment i ever
thought that everything i had been
through
had like a purpose sort of
uh and then she said you can do anything
you want to do it's only your thinking
you can't do it that's going to keep you
from doing it right and and i think it's
it's that knowing you're suffering and
owning your suffering and and leveraging
that suffering as
a vehicle for healing not only yourself
but others that has really been the
touchdown of your life yeah
but to take it back uh just to kind of
back into the timeline here a little bit
before you before you meet deepama i
mean you you go you have this great
story where even before you go to india
you met with a tibetan choker
and you're like what should i do when i
get to india and he's like what does he
he says follow the follow the pretense
of accident that's right and you're like
i don't know what that means right right
it's only it's only later that you
understand but you go and you're kind of
meandering around india and you find
yourself at this
um
at this ashram for this meditation
retreat
and you know unbeknownst to you you're
surrounded by all these people that
ultimately
um return like yourself and become
leaders in this meditation movement
throughout the west yeah joseph
goldstein ram das krishna doss dan
gundlin yeah i mean unbelievable right
that that was your first meditation
retreat like when i see that when i i
mean it's like it gives me chills it's
like
this is you're exactly where you're
supposed to be this was like perfect for
you and this is all meant to be
unfolding in the way that it did
yeah i think it was i
i looked back at that you know that
particular era mm-hmm and i think
amazing you know we're also so close and
we're all still
like doing it in some way or another and
ramdas was rom das at that that's right
right i mean he had already you know he
had already had quite a bit of fame and
notoriety i mean be here now came out
when came out then came he got the box
when we were there together oh he did
wow it arrived look at this you know
yeah yeah yeah so it's like 1971. uh-huh
do you know you probably know bhagavan
das yeah yeah yeah he actually he
married my wife and i really yeah yeah
wow
so for those who don't know bhagavan
actually was a lanky teenager who
ultimately led ramdas to neem karoli
baba right and introduce them and neem
karoli bob of becoming ramdas teacher
and you know the rest is history
um amazing right so so you have this
initial meditation retreat and this is
your introduction i mean that began as a
vipassana retreat yeah it was a pleasure
and it kind of ended with you being
introduced to meta so so maybe describe
the difference between
those two traditions okay so the
question is
a word in pali which is the language of
the original buddhist text it just means
insight meditation so
that one particular style of doing
meditation has come to be associated
with the word vapasana the teacher was
sn goenka and
it was just a kind of mostly mindfulness
of the body and body sensations and
experiencing everything like emotions
and thoughts through those sensations
um
and that he the retreat began with just
a kind of awareness of the breath which
is a
practice most people get familiar with
first
just resting your attention on the
feeling of the breath and bringing your
attention back when it wanders which is
continuous
and then this awareness of the body so
right at the end goenka
led a meta metta
retreat
meditation and that was almost like a
ceremonial way of ending the retreat
mecha means loving kindness in pali so
that was the moment i heard oh there's
another style
there's another way of practicing and
that's kind of interesting it's all
about love it's about filling your being
with the sense of love that's how you
start and extending it
to all others and
i longed for that certainly and i looked
for that for and that became your sweet
spot yeah right and did you were you
aware of that at that moment like this
is going to be my thing no and because i
was so naive or so young and i didn't
know how to i mean i knew that there was
a way of doing it intensively um
with structure and stuff but i didn't
know what it was
and and just so we're clear like so the
vipassana you're you're it's really
focused on the breath but the actual
practice of of meta is repetition of a
mantra but not a mantra in the
traditional sense it's sort of like
these sayings right where you're
emitting loving kindness into the world
yeah it's it we consider it like a
practice of generosity so it's offering
you know instead of um
looking through you i look at you and
and think maybe happy maybe peaceful or
whatever the particular
thing is
and so from there
where do you go from there linka
deepama shortly there after that i met
her probably a year later or nine months
later i stayed in india i practiced with
other teachers i practiced with tibetan
teachers i
um
ended up going back to budgaya which is
where i started with going and kind of
continuing on
in that tradition so i probably met her
that summer summer of 71
something like that and uh
i stayed beyond my year away from
buffalo but then i went back and i did
what i needed to do to get two years of
independent study credit so i did that
and then i went back to india so
ultimately you were in india for like
four years though
yeah
and the idea at the time was you were
just going to stay there right my idea
was
[Laughter]
uh-huh so deepama had a different plan
for you yeah and unbeknownst to you that
plan begins to manifest so you come back
with no intention of of carrying out
this edict that she had laid forth for
you but ultimately that's that's
basically what transpires yeah
yeah but uh rom does it i don't know
when he came back actually but he was
back and uh
joseph goldstein who might met in my
first retreat and we were good friends
he'd come back about six months before i
didn't uh ramdas was teaching uh narepa
institute had just opened up that summer
in boulder it was their inaugural summer
and
is the first buddhist institute now
university in the country and
uh ramdas has like a mega class of like
a thousand people and trunk periphery
who was the same one who said to me you
know follow the pretense of accident
it's his school he founded it wow so he
had like some of the same in some
different thousand people class
and ram just divided his class into like
the meditation subgroup and the
chanting subgroup so joseph was doing
the meditation subgroup and jack
corfield was there teaching his own
class living down the hall so
the joke although it was absolutely true
when i sort of did what i needed to in
new york
was that of all the this group of people
who had gotten quite close in india
joseph was the only one with a job in an
apartment so we all went to boulder
everybody like kind of flopped at his
place yeah there were like nine of us
living in this one bedroom apartment
he tells the story and said it was
absolutely horrible for him he's a very
meticulous person i'm sure he drove him
insane but he said until he stopped
thinking of it as his apartment and it
was just we're all living together right
like he's a rather fastidious yeah
gentleman yeah so yeah
you know he had to have his own journey
with non-attachment that's right he did
you all moved in
so um
he uh
was quite popular with the students and
was asked to stay on for the second
summer session so i stayed on with him
uh
and then
we were invited to teach a one-month
retreat which we did that was the first
recruit we taught
so we did that and then we were invited
to
teach a 10-day retreat up in our
two-week retreat out in vancouver so i
think jack and joseph and i all went up
there and then
it was just like they were sleeping on
people's living room couches right you
had nothing and
a letter would come and say would you
come teach a retreat and we said oh yeah
let's do that right so you're just like
this traveling band of merry meditating
meditation people yeah yeah yeah
but you're getting i mean people are
showing up for this right like it's some
people wear it yeah
maybe if we had 35 people 40 people 50
people were ecstatic
and ultimately this leads to you
founding the insight meditation society
in in massachusetts right so when what
year was that what how many years after
that was six okay so that was two years
so this all happens in a pretty rapid
succession right you take over this
large house and
uh
it's a monastery isn't it [ __ ] yeah and
use a really large house you
institutionalize this yeah and that
exists to this day yeah which is amazing
right and i and i love how it was kind
of uh it was a lark right like is
anybody gonna show up like how are we
gonna pay the mortgage at this place
totally that kind of thing it was like
well what happened before then was that
uh we were just like
crashing at people's houses and
responding to these letters and
somebody has said i think in in great
defense
he said i have another house in felton
like a rental property
why don't you go there and stay there a
while
so that's why i was so amused when jason
moved to felton i said felton that's
where we started out it was like our
first address in this country
so we we went to this house and we did
the only thing we knew how to do which
was opened it as a retreat center so
like three extra bedrooms or something
like that and people would come and do
their own retreat and we'd feed them and
jack cornfield taught his first retreat
ever in that living room there were 19
people wow and um
somebody came through and he said
you know why don't you start a real
retreat center like
and all the people i know who can really
help you their messages it's
somewhere back east uh and we looked up
and down the east coast and finally
found this property in
barrie which was in novitiate and um
it cost 150 000
like this huge institutional building
and 80 acres of land so of course we
didn't have 150 000
in 1975 and
so we raised fifty thousand dollars
the fathers of the blessed sacrament
gave us a fifty thousand dollar mortgage
we couldn't get a bank mortgage
so three very brave people personally
took out loans wow so we could open the
door so our mantra really for the first
year was can i always close in a year
right which didn't make them very happy
but uh that was our mantra because who
knew amazing was there a specific moment
where you kind of consciously realized
that deepama's you know prophecy was
coming true for you i think there wasn't
it was years later yeah i just kept
thinking you know i'll do it for a while
dude for a few months i'll do it then i
think
this is my life actually yeah
and i mean could you have imagined that
you would have you know become this
legendary teacher yeah to travel around
the world and get celebrated
yeah no not at all i mean it's
amazing yeah it's everything it's uh
it's it's quite it's been quite an
amazing journey for you i would say
um
so i want to talk about
uh
this idea and you address this in the
book
and i've talked about this in the past
on the podcast but i think it's super
important and it it it's you know this
the stories that we tell ourselves about
ourselves and how we get caught up in
these narratives that that don't serve
you you know where these stories come
from and how we can you know decouple
that narrative and begin the process of
telling ourselves a new story
uh in the book i also write about uh if
you have a
kind of a prevalent
frequent you know similar critical voice
like your inner critic
sometimes what's good is like
give it a persona give it a name give it
a wardrobe
so i named my inner critic lucy after
the
character in the peanuts comic strip
with apologies to all the lucy's in the
world
um
i'd seen this cartoon where in the first
frame lucy is talking to charlie brown
and she says
you know charlie brown what your problem
is the problem with you is that you're
you
then the second frame poor charlie brown
says what in the world can i do about
that
then in the third and final frame lucy
says i don't pretend to be able to give
advice i merely point out the problem
and somehow whenever i was walking by
this desk i would see that cartoon
and my eye would fall right on the line
the problem with you is that you're you
because that lucy voice had been so
dominant in my early life and i really
credit my meditation training for
uh basically having a different
relationship to lucy you know instead of
on the one hand believing her completely
like you're right lucy you're always
right
or on the other hand hating her and
fearing her and being ashamed and all of
that
i realized i had two
ways of approaching her one was hi lucy
like i see you you know
and the other was chill out lucy right
and you know packed into that is the
idea of becoming the observer as opposed
to identifying with that voice as being
part and parcel of who you are that's
right like wrapping it up into your
identity yeah and it
actually happened very soon after i saw
the cartoon
something great happened for me
and my first thought was it's never
gonna happen again
right
well that's the observer was different
than it's like you're right you know
it's the negative bias right and you
talk about this in the book as well like
we're we're hardwired we're predisposed
to identify these these negative things
that occur to us and
then you know choose to string those
together and create this story about who
we are how we got here and what's going
to happen to us in the future that's
right right
so to expand on that a little bit well i
mean i think it
something that can be confusing for us
is the difference between intentionality
and coercion
and we use a lot of intentionality in
these approaches because
we are conditioned and usually toward
say negativity if you're
thinking about your day and almost like
evaluating yourself like how well did i
do today
it's not uncommon to pretty well only
think about the mistakes and what you
didn't do that well and you didn't show
up that well and you'd say that really
great or
and it takes intentionality to kind of
say anything else happened today
you know it's not hypocrisy it's not
denying that there were issues you know
but
um it's not all that happened
right so to get to a truer bigger
picture
we have to actually move our attention
consciously
towards the good
you know anything good happened today
any good within me
and and that kind of elasticity or
flexibility of attention is also part of
the meditative process um but it begins
really with seeing the story because
not only do we tell stories
about ourselves but others tell stories
about us right
and so um
though those can be very unkind we tell
stories about other people and we tell
stories about other people exactly
you know there's some somebody i also
tell this story in the book somebody um
told me to write a friend of mine he'd
given a lecture somewhere
and in the course of the lecture he
mentioned how
reading proofs remembrances of things
passive and so crucial for him
some stage of his development and
he was at dinner after the lecture and a
group of people came up to him this
woman came forth and
his his assumption about her has thought
about her so she looks like poorly
educated you know she's probably not
very smart
and then she said to him i was at your
lecture so his heart kind of sank you
know what's she going to say
and then she said i just want to say
that
i find reading priest in the original
french must much more fulfilling but i
was like okay
well all right
so
in thinking about that like i'm i'm
thinking about you know of course the
story i tell myself about myself but
also the story that i tell about the
other people that i encounter throughout
my day and that story is generally
reflective of my own state of mind and
how i feel about myself like if i feel
good about myself i'm probably going to
tell a more flattering
version of you know these other people
that i encounter throughout my day
but when you when you really kind of
analyze it like you realize like over
the course of your life billions of
things have happened to you yeah
billions right and we extract out you
know these 10 things that happen over
the course of our life and why we
identify with them so deeply so
thoroughly that they infect and invade
you know every how we see ourselves
every decision that we make how we
interact with other people the words
that come out of our mouth the kind of
entertainment we choose to you know
enjoy whatever it like it's it's amazing
how pervasive it is and it's so cemented
that the idea of even looking at that or
being critical of the veracity of that
let alone reframing it
is something i think most people don't
even begin to engage in
do you agree that's true that's
absolutely true
which is why i think seeing the story
is maybe it's the first and the most
critical step because a lot of people
don't even believe that you know
i was teaching somewhere and somebody
said
i don't really see how others can tell
stories about us
because they don't know us how could
they be telling a story about us and
i said i think everything is telling a
story about us and architecture tells
the story about us
the retreat center i co-founded the
insight meditation society just
um we built on this sort of structure so
that people in wheelchairs can come in
the front door
and it's really big and not very pretty
you know
uh because previously people in
wheelchairs had to go around the side
and then down the back you know it's
snowy and [ __ ] and
uh it wasn't the right story you know to
be telling people about belonging or
inclusion and so you know we raise all
this money we built this thing and i
find it personally very treacherous
because i learned i was a new yorker i
learned how to drive when i was older
right i'm not that great a driver and
i'm parked somewhere beyond and i have
to like back out you know it's like
protruding into the driveway
and i really don't like it but it's the
right story
you know and we don't realize how much
we're impacted by all of those
uh views coming toward us about who we
are
and it takes a great deal of integrity
to have a sense of this is who i am
actually
and the process of of really engaging
that comes back again to honing your
attention yeah right yeah and and you
kind of lay it out in the book in this
four-step process that you call brain
right can you walk me through that
sure rain is something that is often
used especially when um
a difficult emotion comes up but you can
use it many many
ways
so let's say anger comes up
in your experience
rather than dismissing it or explaining
it or hating yourself for it or
plotting revenge you want to just look
at the feeling and this is something
that's rare with strong emotion
usually we get so captivated by the
object like if you really really want
something
you think about the thing like i just
bought a new car
you know so it's like what color and you
know
what thing what feature
we very rarely kind of pivot our
attention to look at the feeling itself
like what does it feel like to want
something so much
or what does it feel like to be so angry
we're so frightened
so that first that's the first step is
kind of pivoting
and then we apply this acronym reign the
first is recognize what's happening like
oh it's anger
uh the second is acknowledge it or
accept it you know don't add on to it
the shame and the
distress and the fear and all of that
just be with it as it is
uh the third is eyes investigate you
know look into it not
why is it here and what am i going to do
about it but
if we really look at a state of anger we
will likely see fear we will see sadness
we may see grief
we'll likely see helpless helplessness
um and we have a much clearer sense of
what is actually cooking you know below
the surface
and we also see it's constantly changing
look at that you know it has just kind
of this nature of arising and passing
away and then and not non-identification
is
you know you don't have to fall into i'm
such an angry person i will be forever
this itself is a passing state and
um it's a very different way of being
with those kinds of emotions
one of the things you talk about in the
book you know a lot of people their
entry point for meditation is
this desire to quell the monkey mind
right like i've got just my mind i can't
you know it's insane
and
and you had a kind of
interesting take on that like it's not
about
getting rid of that as much as it is
not identifying with it or coming into a
different kind of relationship with that
yeah i think it's very much about coming
into a different kind of relationship
with that because
you can't get rid of it you know i mean
that's first of all a hopeless task and
uh it's very embattled you know it's
like tiring
and maybe more than anything these days
if i'm introduced as a meditation
teacher
well probably more than anything people
will respond with i'm so stressed out i
could use some of that
but second comes i tried that once i
failed at it right
because that's what people's notion is i
should have a totally blank mind i
shouldn't have any thoughts i should
have only beautiful thoughts
anxiety shouldn't come back i shouldn't
get sleepy
whereas we say that the essence of the
meditation is not what's happening it's
how we're relating to what's happening
and so any of that might happen but you
could be different with it
you could be more centered you could be
more balanced you'd be more aware you
could be kinder all of that comes into
play as we evolve in the meditation so
it's not that
easy to describe as a metric you know
it's easier to say well that doesn't
happen anymore or i don't get distracted
anymore but to say i come back from
distraction more gracefully with a
better sense of humor
that's not that easy but that's really
what happens yeah it's a gradual thing i
mean you tell the story uh in the book
of dropping the glass yeah right like
thinking that this practice is not
really doing anything for you until you
have this situation where you drop this
class at this class and you don't react
the way you usually do you react with
sort of a you know
a more loving you know response to
yourself right yeah but i think
ancillary like sort of tangentially
related to
this idea of you know people saying i
tried meditation it didn't work for me
because you know my monkey mind's out of
control like baked into that is
this sense of of like perfectionism
right like if i can't do a perfect i'm
not going to do it you know holding
yourself to this certain standard and
the kind of you know
violence that's associated with that and
and how that's really anti-love right
it's isolating and it's it's it's
separating yourself from
others and yourself so how do you
elaborate on that well one of the
pillars of self-compassion as a
psychological theory in current western
psychology is um
understanding we're part of a human
family you know like when you blow it
you're not the only person in life has
ever done that
and and that's a big ingredient in that
kind of changed relationship which again
it's not laziness or excuses for what
you've done or are doing but
it's understanding this is part of the
human condition
and we can't pick up we can begin again
this is resilience
in effect and so
we do have notions of perfection
never thinking that perfection really it
never lasts you know like you have the
perfect piece of fruit and it starts to
decay or i just bought a new car and
it's like
honestly when i left it someone had
pooped on it some creature and it burned
obviously
not a bear but
uh it was like oh no i can't believe it
you know like
where's my perfect car right like making
peace with the fact that truly nothing
is static like our human brains want to
believe that you know
there will always be democracy in
america well maybe i'm not so sure right
now you know like just certain things
that we take for granted like my wife
will always be there and i'll always
live in this house
all of these things and and and and it's
scary to think that
you know to really embrace that
impermanence but
but there's a freedom in that right that
allows you to decouple from you know
these this sense of perfectionism and
other traits well yeah it's free because
it's true you know it's like it sounds
like this fanciful spiritual notion
you're trying to superimpose on reality
it is reality and the further we get
from reality the more we hurt right
because we're like banging our head
against the wall
one of the the benefits for me of
mindfulness practice and meditation
is developing a
you know sort of a more uh objective and
expansive
understanding of
certain character traits and my
relationship to them with the extent to
which they lead me astray or
you know propel me forward so an example
of that in my case is
you know self-will like for my whole
life i thought everything good that ever
happened to me is because i buckled down
and worked hard for it worked harder for
than anybody else i overcame this talent
deficit gap and was able to like get
[ __ ] done right
uh but it's that same
uh
same trait that has led me down many a
dark alley right like sort of that
self-reliance um has detached me from
you know a greater sense of uh you know
engagement in the world and
and when i was struggling with drugs and
alcohol it was the key you know
preventative element from me allowing
myself to get sober because i i
associated surrender with defeat or
weakness etc
so can you talk a little bit about like
how our relationship with our
character traits and you know how we can
develop you know a better understanding
of how they work and how to you know
transcend them well i think that holds
true even for the stories we tell
ourselves i mean a lot of those stories
served a very useful purpose and
some stage of development you know when
you were
putting your alcoholic parents to bed or
you know you were all alone and
trying to struggle you know
i mean you you know your story but
because i don't know your story but
um you know when one is is weaving a
story to
uh survive basically you know once
circumstances often as a child that's a
useful story but when it becomes the
singular story
then we're stuck
and it becomes very difficult to let go
of that it's very difficult because you
have identified so completely with it
and it served you to some extent right
you know and may no longer be serving
and you want
you and you
you become blind to how it's not serving
you right because you are so
self-identified with it yeah
and so how do we work our way out of
that well it all comes back to holding
your attention right attention and these
practices of mindfulness and meditation
yes definitely but since you mentioned
recovery you know
uh there's an
amazing role for community as well you
know it's like that fellowship in the
recovery community
um
is magnificent i wish i could redesign
you know a
12-step group for everything yeah you
know
everything all the principles are
applicable to every human being and
whatever they're challenged by yeah i
mean i've worked with people and i
looked at them and they have
terrible family situations and i said
please tell me someone drinks so you can
go down on you know like
you know like please
and sorry that i drank right you know
um
but because that plays a strong role too
it's like we we reformulate
our sense of what's normal
you know in in human relationship
through relationship
and uh
that that can be very powerful as well
but i've a tremendous amount comes back
to honing attention right and the
journey really you know the at this
you know the risk of
sort of being reductionist about this
whole thing is that
you really have to
engage this inward journey and embrace
it if you want to get to this place of
not completion but
you know sufficient wholeness where you
can love yourself and and be capable of
of loving another and not looking to
someone else you know it's like that
idea you know that jerry maguire like
you complete me is you know such a
a lie that so many people buy into and
and and you know quite honestly leads
them astray and further away from what
they're seeking yeah
definitely and you'll find it everywhere
you know it's just like pulverizing us
that message
you know from every direction and
and uh that's another role for community
actually it's like people to step away
together from
the
prevalent messaging of the society and
to reinforce the strength say i want to
look differently i want to look at it
from another angle
and you know it's a it's a
we're having an amazing moment right now
because
you know meditation and mindfulness
these things are now very much of the
zeitgeist you know and for the majority
of your career they really weren't
uh and and i would imagine that this
cuts both ways for you you know on the
one hand it's kind of amazing now
there's all this science and people are
talking about these ideas that you've
been teaching for so long and it must be
very gratifying on a certain level
to see
the mainstream consciousness uh
adapting and adopting
these tactics and practices
but at the same time i would imagine
there's some level of you know kind of
uh
bastardization of
you know these these principles and
traditions that you hold so dear as they
become kind of diluted so that they can
be digestible to the average human being
so how do you like what is your opinion
definitely well sometimes i identify
myself just this morning to somebody as
i guess being on the left-wing fringe of
the of the orthodoxy because i am of the
orthodoxy you know i had you could say
classical education
um
and i i really studied with
immensely wonderful teachers and
my own teacher told me to teach that's
the old-fashioned way
you know many many people come up to me
and say i'm a mindfulness teacher and i
don't even know what that means anymore
it used to be i'd say well who was your
teacher because then i'd know something
like they said tik nadhan i think a
social action if they said somebody else
i think oh you know that's like intense
concentration or whatever
but i don't even know what it means
anymore um
anybody can be a mindfulness anybody no
it's the wild west you know there's no
licensing there's nothing but
on the one hand i am i am of the far
left wing because i think it's great
i i think it's tremendous so many times
somebody will come up to me and say i'm
a mindfulness teacher and the next thing
i'll say is i'm teaching that hellish
prison
and i think well i'm not you know god
bless you that's great
uh you know people are sincerely
motivated and mostly and and
uh really doing a great service to a lot
of people
you know i have great issues around a
couple of things one is
the nature of the training um
there's an emphasis these days in this
society in this time on scaling as
though that was the the greatest virtue
you know that fewer people going to a
greater depth is not enough
it needs to be more and more and more
people
doing the thing even if it's quite
superficially and so
that means you need more and more and
more instructors or you need you know
and so how are they trained you know are
they trained or
are they just out there and it's not
good for them as people the instructors
and it's
not really serving the other people i
was reading a study the other day
that you know the headline was
surprising to me it said something like
mindfulness in contradiction to many
other studies
mindfulness does not um
lead to empathy
and i thought i don't get that because
i've read so many studies and i know it
anyway but you know i've read so many
studies that show the opposite so then i
was reading the actual study
and it turned out that the training the
mindfulness training was five minutes
long
literally it was five minutes long and
and i thought oh my god and then
the
you know the principal investigator and
people were challenged about that and
they said well these other studies were
just
using five minutes of meditation and
they showed something or other so
that was like the standard and i thought
five minutes is like you know yeah
right right right i mean that there's
still a long way to go yeah that's what
i read into that
um but there is something about
you know the the the respect for the
teacher you know what i mean i mean
right now it's like we have access to
you know at our fingertips in our in
everybody's pocket you know you have the
universe available to you and you can
access these
practices whether it's through headspace
or dan's app 10 happier i know you
you're involved in that and you know
there's a there's a plethora of other
ones that probably vary in quality the
good information is available but
there's also you know a lot of garbage
so it requires a little bit more
discernment but that tactile experience
of like sitting at the foot of a master
you know we've sort of gotten away from
that you know and and i think there's a
reverence for that that we should
perhaps appreciate a little bit more
fully yeah i think it's
it's a beautiful thing and it's
like
you know when my friend joseph gossey
was um first in asia he was actually in
the peace corps and he was just a school
teacher
uh teaching english and
he said when he walked into the room
he was in thailand his students would
bow
because it's a culture of respect
for the teacher you know like we're like
hurling chairs at our teachers
yeah it's different it's different um
you know on some level though i guess
the counterpoint is i mean you know my
personal story like when i got out of
rehab like i started going to yoga and i
went to the yoga class in brentwood
where they played hip-hop music and
there was lots of pretty girls and i
don't know whether i would have gone to
yoga otherwise but that was my welcome
mat you know what i mean and it allowed
me to walk in the door and i've since
gone on a journey with that that has
taken me to a very different place
but but had i been told like you have to
do it this way and you've got to find
this kind of teacher like i might not
have walked through that door to begin
with so there's a you have to kind of um
have a respect for the individual and
say look let's just get you a track
let's dangle this like shiny object in
front of you you know what i mean and
trust that if this resonates with you
that you'll then grab that and and take
it to a different place yeah i mean i
think that's very true and and that
um
you know it's a teacher like you kind of
have to find your own place like what
feels right to you
in terms of the context the languaging
the
uh you know do you teach a yoga class
where people can't home or do they you
know think they're stretching
um right it could be anything and it's
all beneficial to someone
and you know as a as an individual
looking for
a system or a teacher i think i i know
it's a weird and awkward way of saying
it but i usually say you have to be a
consumer
you know you have to feel what's right
for you and
go there
you know don't hang out with the people
in the place and the
where you feel like oh this is weird you
know right
yeah because then you're not in the long
run you're going to tap out right yeah
but on this subject of teachers you know
ramdas talks about this like we you know
in our in our culture
we have great reverence for
the intellectuals you know and he uses
lincoln and einstein and we put these
people up on a pedestal and or or
athletes right lebron james you know
michael jordan with these people these
are the people that that are the icons
of our culture
what we don't do is
celebrate the spiritual masters you know
the the great teachers of
of developing consciousness like they do
in india you know and i could see you as
a young person in india like realizing
that's very much the culture there right
that respect and that reverence for
these these individuals that hold that
you know capacity that we just lack in
our western culture you know is there
like
can we shift that like can do you see a
future in which we can develop that kind
of
reverence or you could see the ascension
of these kinds of consciousness
you know consciousness wielding
individuals um
you know holding that kind of stature
i think i can and i think it's gonna
come about in a kind of strange way
because
uh as i was listening to just now i
started thinking about my first trip to
soviet union
and going to the um grave of different
grave sites of different poets
and you'd think these people were rock
stars you know and
and we don't treat poets that way either
necessarily or artists or you know
and i think this is the kind of time
where when people talk about social
action and social justice and movements
i always say what about the artists you
know like i have a feeling that's going
to lead the
the way and and
you know people express their deepest
values in different ways and have
different strengths but
i think that there's going to be a whole
breakaway of communication and
expression through art through through
all those those media
and i think that's going to bring about
a whole other sense of consciousness
which will include
kind of strict consciousness movements
and you know people
teaching meditation and things like that
i think it's
uh it's going to form the kind of
radical edge yeah
i would like to see that i would like to
see that happen we're certainly in a
moment where you know we need art
desperately for sure and i could see
that you know i i think that
that there's you know a fertile
environment for that to occur
you know but at the same time we're
you know we're more distracted than ever
you know these devices that we have that
we think are are
connecting us more deeply with our
fellow human are actually alienating
yeah i mean and i have a weird
relationship with social media because
of what i do like i'm very connected and
tapped in and and it's allowed me to
connect with amazing people you know
like i've been able to
meet in person
you know phenomenal individuals all
across the world as a result of that
platform
but i have to keep my relationship with
it in check so that i'm not just sitting
at home
like you know what kids disconnected
right so so it's like yeah i can use the
10 happier app or i can use headspace
and and and yet that's not a replacement
for being out in the world and
cultivating you know community and these
things so how do you talk about that
when you when you're teaching these
principles well i think it's really true
and i think it is a matter of restraint
and i also i love technology and i think
of myself often at the age of 18 going
off to india
and like so scared and
so determined and i you know i'd never
even been to california before when i
went to india
and but i needed to go to india you
don't have to go to india as you say
anymore and
uh very very fine teachings and
approaches are available through your
phone
um but what's missing is the community
aspect often and so
uh it can't replace having a living
sense of some connection with another
human being
but it often does and so i think it's
tremendously freeing when i've taught
things online you know and i've seen um
you know people in poland doing it or
you know people all over the world doing
it and
uh it's amazing to me that it really is
kind of this global community now you
know it's not it's not it allows these
ideas to travel yeah instantaneously
it's amazing people can have the
experience you know they don't have to
think wistfully of like if only i could
get a visa you know or
whatever it might be
but we we i think definitely need first
of all we need discipline you know
because
i have a friend who um
every time we have dinner together we'll
tweet it out each of us will tweet out
having dinner with zonzo and once we're
in a restaurant doing that and somebody
knew him and they came up to him and
said are you going to talk to each other
at all
in your friends a little time because
your people do stay on their phones all
the time yeah the optics are not great
like the meditation teachers are on
their phones sitting across from each
other
exactly that's what it looked like and
that's what it was
um
but i think you know we can be
reasonable we can learn to be reasonable
about it the other thing people tell me
uh like i'm a professor friend who was
talking about his students
and he said people
his students he felt really used the
media of you know online communication
social media
uh
just as a means of comparison and kind
of putting other people down like people
don't post a photo of their imperfect
meal um
you know and i said i first i said i
wonder if that's an age thing because my
people are usually posting like about
their shoulder surgery or something like
that you know our aches and pains and
complaints but
um
there's something about that you know
that some consciousness that needs to
enter like what are we really trying to
communicate
and if we feel completely inauthentic
over and over and over again because
it's just some act
you know then it's clearly not serving
us and we need to find that somewhere
else yeah it requires discernment you
know i mean you can use that to again go
back to the stories we tell ourselves
about ourselves you can use that
um
to fuel that story that's not serving
you look at how much better everybody
else is doing everybody's doing great
i'm doing terrible it's never going to
happen for me you know whatever that
self-defeating narrative is yeah
so
and that discernment is a journey
towards self-love right yeah so back to
back to exactly you know back to real
love and and within that is you know
judgment right and so
how do we you know
and healthy boundaries correct right so
how do we
exercise healthy boundaries in the
practice of real love and self-love like
when we're
you know if there's people in our life
that you know that we need to
exercise from our experience you know
what i mean like like how do you do that
in a way that's still compassionate like
how you know you know what i'm talking
about yeah i mean one of
the things we would say is is really
having a sense of clarity about where
in a way like where love and compassion
reside which
we would say is in one's motivation or
intention it's not in the action so it's
like it's like the same as tough love
you know
or fierce compassion
uh
the the arena of the psyche that is
supposed to be most transformed through
the practice or deepening of loving
kindness
and compassion is the arena of
motivation or intention so
if for example you have largely been
motivated by fear in what you do or what
you say or what you hold back from doing
or saying
and you deepen these qualities you'll be
largely motivated by a sense of
connection
you know but that doesn't determine what
you'll do
you know out of that care that
connection even that kindness
in the moment there's a there's a real
discernment that needs to take place
which is very very contextual
you know in this moment in this
particular point in time in this
relationship
what do i feel is the most skillful way
to say this or most skillful thing to do
is it yes or no
is it giving them the money or not
giving them the money and you know we
make mistakes for sure i call it our
best guess
but it's it's discernment it's different
than the care
and we conflate those two and that's the
place where people often say well i
don't know about that love thing you
know then i can only be sweet and
say yes and right it gets it's murky if
you're a people pleaser yeah because
then you think self-love or loving
others is is is basically just always
being available to what they want and
and doing what they want to do and
that's that's a lack of self-love right
because you aren't discerning and you're
not creating a healthy boundary yeah i
mean you have to and so uh
i would
so in teaching i go over that point
again and again and again and again you
know they're different you can be coming
from a really loving motive really
loving place and your best guess of the
right way to act in this moment in time
is really fierce
it's really intense it's having a strong
boundary it's saying no
i'm not going to give you more money no
you can't move in again
and you don't have to feel like that
indicates a lack of love in your heart
because it doesn't necessarily at all
and the way you know the difference is
by looking you know right is by paying
attention
this is all a journey towards
self-actualization and and and really
you know embodying your most authentic
self right and getting to a place where
you can trust your instincts and those
impulses that arise are the signals that
you know are the the light the lampposts
on your on your path
but if you're
i think it gets confusing because if
you're not in a good place or if those
impulses and instincts are being driven
by
addiction or that unhealthy narrative
then they're not they're not trustworthy
instincts right so how do you how do you
know when you can trust them and and and
allow them to light your path and when
do you know like you know what like i
need some more i got to do a little bit
of more work before i can trust
whatever's arising in me yeah well i
mean it's never bad to have the thought
i need to do some more work yeah because
we usually all need to do some more work
but i think some of that has to do with
community sometimes like other people
saying you really should chill you know
that was that was kind of hard right uh
and sometimes it has to do with just
buying time like i have a friend who
who said she could never say no to
people and so in her meditation practice
one day she kind of brought up in her
mind that kind of scenario
as an act of creative imagination like
when she was asked a question where she
really should say no
and she felt was happening in her body
this kind of almost panic
that would viscerally start taking over
like they won't love me anymore you know
whatever
and she used that
that sensation
as a kind of feedback system
so that when she was in an actual
situation like at work and somebody
would ask her that very kind of question
and she would feel that sort of panic
begin to come over her
she would say i can't answer you quite
yet or i need a little time like she
couldn't say no
but if she had more time she could say
no
so she's right it's like it's like uh
uh writing out that email but not
sending it that's right exactly right
but don't send it and so you know you
need certain curbs in place like that
you know that as a matter of discipline
rooms play you know like i'm gonna
today whenever i write an email i'm not
gonna send it right away or something
like that that's a discipline
um but within that you can you also need
to be kind to yourself you know and not
say i'm like a wretched person i can
never say no you could say oh look at
this is that habit
i'm not going to let it hold sway again
how do you create you know healthy
boundaries around yourself when you know
everybody wants a piece of you you know
you know it's like a it's it can be like
a vampiric thing right if you if you
don't have that boundary like everyone's
sucking you dry and and as a teacher and
as somebody who's holding a certain
frequency that people want and and you
know gravitate towards you
you got to take care of yourself or you
can't take care of them yeah no it's
true and that
first of all you need to remember
that very fact yeah you know that's very
true and then
um
you know i feel really lucky i still
have teachers and i still consider
myself a student and i still practice
and
uh
without that i can't even imagine you
know what it would be like and right and
i think there's something about
authenticity which is very important
because
sometimes in
trying to please that image
you know and you have to live up to yeah
this idea of who everybody thinks that's
right that's right it's crazy training
you know i just told this story like a
couple of trips ago i was in the san
francisco airport and my flight was six
and a half hours late
and i was fine for five and a half hours
so it was really mellow and then i was
like really getting impatient and
uh and just then somebody came up to me
and said are you sharing songs
right i thought damn you know like you
should come up an hour ago yeah i was in
a much better place or somebody taking a
video of you chewing out the airline
person
it goes viral
nobody wants that nobody wants that you
know
yeah it's it's gotta be difficult i
would imagine so what does your practice
look like
um i practice every day uh
different lengths my goal is to try to
do like 40 minutes a day if not all at
once then in chunks you know um
i try to practice in informal times like
walking down the streets of especially
with loving kindness
uh walking down the streets of new york
city or sitting on an airplane silently
repeating may you'd be happy or may all
beings be happy
which is quite fun it's all other way of
being in new york
um
and i try to do retreats at least
periodically but it's the i think it's
the everydayness of it that really saves
me right so there's the formal part of
the practice and then there's
carrying that into
your interactions in the world which is
a form of practice in and of itself
right yeah
so what are the what are the challenges
that you
still face like when you have like what
are the what are the things that you're
working on overcoming or improving on
yeah well i mean i think it's some of it
is like this energy gap you know it's
like
every time i feel like i'm like at the
right level of energy something more is
asked of me
and so i feel like i'm always in a gap
pretty well
and and needing to you know somehow meet
that
um
i think one of the greatest challenges i
have is just like
it's not exactly a challenge it's more
like a
process you know of feeling like
um
it's it's a little strange when people
kind of know your name you know and
but the things that make you happy are
the things that always made you happy
you know which are very simple
and so remembering that that's what
counts you know and that's that's a life
that's your life
and it's simply being with friends or
it's simply hanging out or looking at
the flowers or i like the light in l.a a
lot you know just looking at the light
and uh
remembering that that's my life you know
and everything else is like this overlay
that exists somewhere else
and how does that get
reconciled with
you know this idea
you know like
of the buddha like i'm working towards
enlightenment you know what i mean like
it can be very achievement oriented yeah
yeah
well i mean i can get there you know
i really like meditation as an art form
and which is why you know i'd like to
devote more time again to it just
uh for the sheer
you know art form of it you know and the
places one can go and
in one's mind and consciousness and
things like that
um i don't feel like driven to get
enlightened in this lifetime i think
it's likely to take more than one
lifetime
uh but i do feel it's possible you know
i don't i don't um
i think the ultimate goal of meditation
is to be a little less stressed out yeah
you know i think that there are things
we're capable of as human beings as
ordinary human beings
uh in the matters of wisdom and love
that are incredible and
sure i would like to be there you know
and i i've never lost sight of that you
know that possibility
have you met people that you feel are
truly enlightened beings
yeah i mean i think deepen my for
example although she would never say she
was completely done you know that would
be
i can't even imagine her saying that um
but she would be an example and like
the most super humble person you can
imagine and her
her love her compassion was also very
maternal it would be like
would you like another cup of tea
you know or can i get you something or
how was your journey or right just
grounded in the real world yeah yeah
what do you make of these stories that
you hear
you know more in the hindu tradition of
these
you know famous you know yogi's that go
into the cave and don't eat for months
on end or become heretarians or you know
these crazy stories of you know you hear
these insane stories right of like they
have superpowers almost right are these
apocryphal like no i don't think i don't
think they're i mean some of them
probably are possible you know some are
probably completely untrue
but uh
not necessarily i mean i think there's
um
at least in the buddhist tradition
there's a at some schools of the
buddhist tradition there's a pretty
clear delineation between
paths of power and paths of wisdom
you know so if you if you develop really
really really strong concentration
only pretty much only that's a path of
power because you're taking like the
energy of the universe and bringing it
to yourself and
um it's from that place that people
develop what we would call psychic
powers or
paranormal abilities so and it's from a
place of mindfulness and clear seeing
and wisdom that we develop qualities
like love and
you know so it's very different
although they support one another
sometimes but you could develop power
without love and then all you've got is
powers it's dark power
so they said dipa ma for example my
teacher
uh in her youth she was trained in those
concentration techniques and she could
do things like that and
like what walk through walls over really
you know um
go back in time and hear the buddha give
a talk
or
go back in time and see where you were
in your previous life or
uh visit different realms of ex
existence or
um
things like that she could you know so
oh you hear those new crowley baba
stories about right reading your minds
and so yeah so if you read like
autobiography of a yogi there's lots of
stories in there about stuff like that
yeah so i have a friend i have friends
who like
are completely freaked out at the notion
of duperman walking through a wall you
know i mean that's that's heavy right
but it's like it's so irrelevant to who
she was you know like
people don't talk about i mean they say
that she could take a
potato and bake it in her hand and make
it taste like chocolate
but people don't ever yeah i mean who
cares no matter how much you like
chocolate i didn't like neem crowley was
it neem crit knows was it new curly
bobber no maybe it was maharishi who
took like a bunch of acid and it didn't
nothing nothing happened right
yeah maybe i don't know
definitely
and
you know so but i say to them those very
friends they say well do you believe
some of those new cruelly baba stories
about him knowing what was happening
with your family in the states which you
didn't even know about yet or they said
oh absolutely because that's the mind
that's not materiality
but if you ask somebody who you know has
studied it they'll say what they do is
they say you know material stuff is said
to be made of earth air water in space
or if they're watering fire in space
and they can separate the elements
so
apparently when somebody like d from
what looks at that wall she sees the
space that's what she goes through
and it seems like a it seems like almost
like a less
cultured or sophisticated attainment
than your mind being able to you know
it's it's considered very it's like
fundamental in a way
so um
i don't get why it's so
uh bizarre to people compared to the
other bizarre things that we
experience and accept yeah i guess it's
a it's how you it's how you frame it
right i mean it's so beyond our
imagination to you know believe that
somebody could do that but you know
and we could go down that rabbit hole
for a long time that's that's crazy
stuff though
but we should land this plane um
we'll get back to the more grounded
space here
you know people
there's a lot of people that listen to
this that are you know they're in
they're into meditation they're into
mindfulness practices there's also a lot
of people that flirt with the idea and
don't actually do it so somebody's
listening to this and they're like you
know the time is now like i'm ready like
i'm i'm down with sharon how can i begin
you know how how can i begin this
journey like how can you kickstart
somebody into
this adventure
i think these days there's so many ways
you can get dan harris's app for example
10 happier or another app you know that
you you feel interested in or a book
um or a class you know i think the
important thing is just
enough clarity in the beginning so you
don't torture yourself by ideas of what
should be happening
and that doesn't take much but some some
reassurance like yes it's normal to be
thinking it's okay that you always get
distracted you can just begin again
that's the point and with that then it's
a question of your own practice and so i
usually say
maybe
whatever is comfortable for you 15
minutes a day for a month or 10 minutes
a day for a month just do that you know
and then you'll see if you want to do it
yeah make a commitment that's reasonable
yeah you know that's not so outlandish
that you're going to abandon it three
days in
and then you know create a little
accountability around it i mean i you
talk about this a lot like you know tell
people this is what you're gonna do and
and and get yourself on the hook you
know what i mean so that at least
there's a little you know not shame but
like you know you're gonna feel like
you know you're you're a little
emotionally invested in this yeah and
there's some support for you you know
and if you don't have anybody in your
town or whatever or any friends that are
going to be of like mine then seek it
virtually you know use that computer in
your pocket and and find groups online
and these apps have accountability built
into them as well like reminders and you
know little things like that that can
allow you to do that do you have like uh
uh
a
um loving kindness practice that you
could kind of share somebody could that
somebody could walk away from this and
start to do
sure i mean uh the simplest one is
probably choose like
two or three phrases that are the gift
you would like to give to yourself like
may it be peaceful may i
calm down you know
but they need to be big enough so you
can then use the same pretty much the
same phrases for others
uh so that's why people use things like
maybe happy may be peaceful
and just sit quietly for a few moments
and make that offering to yourself and
just keep repeating the phrases your
mind will wander everywhere don't worry
about that
uh you can let go of the distractions
one by one it's okay and just come back
to the phrases don't like count on some
tremendous feeling coming up and uh just
do it a little bit then think of
somebody you really care about
uh usually someone has helped you that
even if you've never met them they've
inspired you
um
and offer the phrases to them even if
the words don't seem perfect they're
like a conduit
for that way of connecting and then just
for fun
have that person or for the phrases back
to you
so that you're in the position of the
recipient
yeah that's a weird feeling yeah right
yeah that brings up all kinds of weird
emotions it does you know it's
interesting when you do that yeah so i
just gave you a very provocative
exercise rather than once that's good
what about like you know sometimes like
i'll develop a resentment against
somebody else and and it will like
monopolize my thinking and it really
undermines the quality of my day or my
week
right so
uh you know in recovery they say like
you know pray for that person like wish
them well so there's a i'm sure there's
a loving kindness version of that where
you're like wishing well on that person
because you're the one who's suffering
as a result of that resentment right and
the path to freedom
is by you know decoupling yourself from
that emotion
exactly and i wouldn't neglect in that
case loving kindness for yourself
uh i would intermingle it either start
with yourself and move to that person or
uh do yourself together may we be happy
may we be peaceful
because you're right you know of course
resentment is such a corrosive
relentless feeling and
it's so obsessive it's like the amount
of time
any of us can spend going through the
list of someone's faults and
then we go through it again and then
again and again and then again and
you know it's very tiring
beautiful
i think we did it all right how do you
feel i feel great you feel good yeah
awesome well i really appreciate you
taking the time uh the work you do is
very meaningful and i hope that you
continue to do it
um the new book is fantastic uh
everybody should pick it up along with
the other eight billion books that
you've
written
what ten now this is number two this is
number ten right and you have a podcast
right i seem to yeah the meta hour
that's right
so it's really great i i uh in the
course of preparing for this i listened
to a bunch of episodes and i really
enjoyed it so that's very cool as well
and in the course of rolling out this
book i'm sure you're going to be out in
the world in a way that you probably
aren't usually are you you have some
speaking engagements coming up or i can
people just find that on your website
it's all on my website right so awesome
love wide love deep
see you guys soon peace plants
[Music]
you